Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie,
Star Wars just made a huge announcement
about a bunch of Mando verse stuff
coming in the next couple of years
There's a second Mandalorian in Grogu movie,
Ahsoka Season 2
The Mandalorian Season 4,
and the Thrawn movie
That heir to the Empire movie.
So we'll break it all down in how it all fits
in the timeline together, Because they did leave.
A couple of questions.
In traditional Star Wars fashion,
they make announcements, but they also raise
a bunch of questions in those announcements.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
Of course, I'll do episode videos for everything
they wind up releasing in big videos
for the movies that they wind up releasing to.
But literally.
Just this morning big surprise.
Star Wars made the announcement.
It's mostly about the Mandalorian in Grogu movie.
But within that announcement about that upcoming movie,
there were like three or four smaller announcements,
lots of zooming enhancing and like rereading
this paragraph of stuff that they released.
so The
Mandalorian and Grogu movie
is meant to be totally separate
from the Thrawn movie that Dave Filoni was announced
to be doing a little while ago.
Jon Favreau is going to direct The Mandalorian
and Grogu you pretty safe bet having Jon Favreau do it.
he's that at least a couple movies
before that have earned a little bit of money.
Like he literally started the MCU with Robert Downey
Jr in the first Iron Man movie
but that Mandalorian and Grogu
movie is literally meant to be the next Star Wars movie
that we see in theaters
It does not mean that they're canceling
The Mandalorian Season four, according to deadline
in their reporting, they followed up and they said that
they're still making The Mandalorian season four.
It is happening after the Mandalorian Grogu movie.
Now in on the other side of that
because they just announced this Mando and Kroger
movie being their next big movie
it means that they've shifted
the release dates of all the other movies
that they announced last year.
If you don't remember, rewind to last year.
In 2023, it's Star Wars celebration.
They announce several upcoming movies.
all those have been delayed
and they've opted for sanity.
They they chosen their most popular two characters
right now to be their first new movies since 2019.
personally, I think that's a no brainer for them.
Like there were a couple of controversial choices like,
who are we going to have be the next Star Wars movie?
Like, what's going to get people's asses into theaters?
Why don't we go with our two most popular characters
in one of our most proven directors?
a lot of their talk
the last couple of months made it sound like
the Rey movie was going to be the next big movie
they actually do.
There's the Origin of the Jedi movie
that's being made at the beginning of the timeline.
There's the Thrawn movie that Dave Filoni is also doing
and they're still doing that.
Taika Waititi Star Wars movie that they haven't
really talked about that much recently.
before all this, if Star Wars had been looking
for a safe bet for their first big movie,
I would have said they probably just moved
the Thrawn movie up and do that sooner.
But it sounds like Star Wars was given an edict
to get a movie into theaters as soon as possible
with the strongest director, the strongest material,
strongest characters as possible
that people just generally tend to enjoy in that
wound up being Jon Favreau, The Mandalorian and Grogu.
You now I do think the Thrawn movie is going
to be a banger when they eventually do get to that.
But there were a couple of issues with the Ahsoka
series and the setting of the Thrawn character up.
Just generally audiences aren't quite as familiar
with him, So I think that's why they delayed that
a little bit to give them some more time during Ahsoka
season two to set him up a little bit better.
and even though Dave Filoni is kind of
become the new Kevin Feige, he has Star Wars,
which has all been expecting to happen for a long time.
he isn't quite as proven as a director or quite as
experienced is a live action director as Jon Favreau.
So Jon Favreau is just the safe
bet between the two of them.
To direct that next movie,
Dave Filoni will eventually direct his Thrawn movie.
but you can see what's happening
behind the scenes here.
Like evil Emperor overlord
Bob Iger is telling the Star Wars
people get a movie in the theaters
as fast as possible, as strong as possible.
in none of those other movies were ready to go.
So that's really like, okay, what are we going to do?
Well, we'll do a Mandalorian and Grogu
a movie seems like a safe bet.
Pretty much all the trades are reporting
that that Jon Favreau
Mandalorian Grogu movie is going to start filming later
this year.
They didn't list a release date,
but if they really move, they might be able
to release it by Christmas 2025.
If not, then then they'll probably just delay
it till Christmas 2026.
pretty much everything in Hollywood got delayed
a little bit longer because of all the strikes.
Normally I would say 2025, but it could be 2026.
inside that larger announcement about the new movie.
They also revealed Dave
Filoni is still doing a circus Season two.
It's confirmed now pretty much everybody
that worked on it, like Rosario Dawson,
even Hayden Christensen, were pretty sure
they were going to get a season two.
here's the thing, though.
They didn't say whether or not it's releasing before
or after the Grogu movie,
but it takes them about a year
to turn seasons of those shows around.
And Dave Filoni was working on scripts
before the strike started last year.
The report was late last year
that they were almost done with those scripts,
like they still need a little bit more work
before they could actually start filming.
some of those characters from Asoka
might cameo during The Mandalorian and Grogu movie,
but they're saving their mega crossover, their Avengers
end game like Star Wars endgame, the Mandalorian
endgame for the Thrawn movie, which isn't happening
until a couple of years down the road.
that means that The Mandalorian and Grogu
movie will mostly be just them
with a couple of cameos from other characters
like the Mandalorians, like Bo-Katan,
maybe a Luke Skywalker cameo, maybe Ezra Bridger, Hera
But remember right now in the timeline, Ahsoka,
the rest of that cast is basically stuck in the parity,
a galaxy with a few exceptions.
so those characters that are stuck in the other galaxy
like Ahsoka, for instance,
probably won't figure into the plot of the Mando
Grogu movie that much,
which is why it's a little bit easier for them to film
Ahsoka Season two this year,
while they're also filming The Mandalorian and Grogu
a movie, most of the Mando Grogu
movie will involve the Mandalorian's Grogu
learning about Thrawn, some of the other plot details
that would have normally been covered
during the Mandalorian Season four
was some other main villain for the movie
who is not Thrawn now, like Thrawn
will probably figure some way into the movie,
but because they're saving the big culminated
in this whole arc for the Thrawn movie,
that means that New Hope Empire Strikes Back.
Return of the Jedi style.
Thrawn is their emperor in this equation.
he won't be the main big bad in this first new movie.
merely theory right now
is that they'll just introduce a new character
from the lore from this part of the timeline
that we haven't seen on the shows before.
It could literally be anybody.
So let me know in the comments
if it's going to be a new character.
Who do you want to be
the main villain of this Mando Grogu movie?
keep in mind that it could also be a force
sensitive person, too.
we got all of those Undead Knights sisters
that came back with Thrawn in the other night.
Sisters.
Like all those,
it seemed like they contained the dead bodies
of nine sisters that they were going to be raising.
moving on.
I've already done a bunch of videos about Ahsoka
season two, so I'll post links down
the description below and at the end of this.
But the plot of that won't change that much
because of the Mando and Grogu movie.
Remember, they're mostly stuck in that other galaxy,
so they'll just be following up with everything
that they tease at the end of season one.
All those big cliffhangers Ahsoka Sabine, who yangu
Yang Shin hate making it back to the main galaxy.
Somehow more mannequin Skywalker
Young Ahsoka flashbacks are more force
ghost and can Skywalker in present day helping Asoka
Hayden Christensen said that all of his cameos
in the past year or so, like between Obi-Wan
Kenobi coming back on Silk,
basically reinvigorated his acting career
like he signed with the new Agency for Representation
after Ahsoka season one happened.
so he's definitely coming back
they still have to figure out if they want to recast
balance school or pay off his storyline
with the more gods in some other way.
But Dave Filoni did revealed that
they will pay off his Mortis Gods storyline somehow.
There's also that teaser with Thrawn,
the Knights sisters establishing
their base of operations on Dathomir
in the main galaxy,
beginning to raise the undead Knight sisters
Thrawn beginning to marshal the collective forces,
the different factions of the Shadow Council
from around the galaxy, the Remnant Empire
in the have revealed
that they're not going to be giving a bunch of the plot
from Asoka to Mando and Grogu, who most of that for now
is just going to stay on the Ahsoka Season two series
with like a little bit of crossover, like Mando Grogu
start to figure out what's going on with Thrawn.
but all the stuff they set up on Asoka
they'll continue to follow up on in Asoka Season two.
if Asoka season two is released before the Mando Grogu
movie, then right after the Mando grogu
movie would either be Skeleton Crew season two
because they're getting ready to release season one.
If they give that to season two,
it could be a one off season, But that's meant
to be connected to the Mandalorian
in the Asoka series in this part of the timeline.
So, like, those characters
will eventually show up in the Thrawn movie
because we haven't seen the series yet, we don't know
exactly how it's going to connect with the storyline
that's happening on Mando in Asoka right now,
But we should learn pretty soon about that,
there might be a couple other spinoff TV series
that they released.
But then next obviously would be The Mandalorian Season
four, which would connect
all of the Thrawn storylines with each show,
all the characters meeting, in
they probably end Mando Season four in a cliffhanger
when the Thrawn movie is beginning.
then the Thrawn movie happens.
It's their big movie version of Heir to the Empire.
It starts probably like Revenge of the Sith.
That's my early theory.
Like they start in the middle of a giant space
battle, stuff that you could only do with the big movie
level budget in
they're not going to release the Thrawn movie
till at least one year
after the Mandalore and Grogu movie.
Maybe a little bit longer.
Might be two years between movies in all the TV shows
fill the gaps between that.
Now that doesn't count the acolyte TV
show The bad Batch Season three tells the Jedi
any other Star Wars spinoff shows
that aren't connected to everything else.
But basically what's happened
is the Star Wars people accelerated the mando verse
line of movies and they're doing them first
before they shift to other parts of the timeline
because they are the safe bet for them,
which I honestly think is the path of sanity.
Like if anybody had to pick what the next Star Wars
movie was going to be, it would probably be something
with Grogu who in Mando,
I'm sure there are going to be a thousand
other questions just based on this announcement.
Like, there's so many things that the Star Wars
people did not answer.
so post all your big questions in the comments below
and I'll try to answer as many of them as I can.
They didn't say when.
Skeleton crew
or the Acolyte series are premiering this year,
but they'll be the big live action
Star Wars series later this year.
we'll probably get the first big trailer
for one of those in the next couple of months.
At some point.
links for all my Star Wars
videos down the description below.
Click here to learn
more about what's going on with Ahsoka Season 2
and click here for that brand new Deadpool
3 teaser trailer.
Thank you so much for watching.
Happy New Year and I'll see you guys in the next one!